I want you Dave Ramsey sure listeners to
hear the nuance in that call okay that's
a sweet lady a smart lady with a
master's degree stressed out
first babies on the way new marriage did
you hear her say she had a hundred and
sixty five thousand dollars in student
loan debt did you hear her say her
parents didn't know so one of the things
we tell folks all the time and I get a
lot of pushback a lot of you get angry
with me as I said we don't have a
student loan crisis as much as we have a
parenting crisis there's no possible way
one of my college-age kids is gonna be
in school running up a hundred
sixty-five thousand dollars of student
loan debt and I don't know because I'm
gonna know where they're going to school
and I want to know where their what the
resources are to pay for it and I can do
6th grade math and see that this child
is getting ready to make a dadgum mess
of her life and I'm gonna pull the plug
on this crap because she went to a
school that was ludicrous to pay that
much to get that degree is just crazy
it's crazy land now she's there and I'm
not picking on her but but because I
mean she's fighting through this stuff
I'm on her team I'm helping her you're
helping her you're praying for that or
listening I know that so we're not
picking on you no Natalie that's not the
goal here that's not without the point
but the point is some of you parents you
need to put your arm around your kid and
give them the word the word is no no
you're not gonna go $165,000 in debt to
get a degree at a private university
they'll afford you the ability to make
seventy or eighty thousand dollars a
year that's called stupid land no no
you're not gonna do that and you parents
have got to get in the middle of their
lives and help them guide because their
18 year old brains don't work I'm sorry
if you're 18 and you don't like that but
your brain doesn't work like your
parents brain works
because their 18 year old brains make
decisions like that this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]